Oh
people are amazed that there is
something called the SETI post-detection
task group and I chair this and it's an
awesome responsibility I say if ET calls
on my watch I'll be among the first to
know and the not only the fate of the
earth but the fate of the entire galaxy
may rest in my hand so it's not
something to be undertaken lightly of
course the people on this committee
think it's it's very hypothetical but
it's a tiny tiny chance that this is
ever going to happen but it's as well
that we think through the issues and and
there are a number of issues because I
think if we suddenly did discover we're
not alone in the universe the
ramifications for that could be very
profound indeed now I like to make a
distinction between two extremes one is
that we just stumble across some sort of
evidence that there's somebody out there
that there's alien technology we can't
say anything more than that might be
that there's some distant star that's
got some signs of tampering or the
planets around that star sometimes of
tempering it's worth remembering that
all technology leaves a footprint for
example our own technology is leaving a
footprint in terms of global warming
which could be detected from a long way
away one assumes that a very advanced
civilization that's been around maybe
millions of millions of years would have
an even bigger footprint that might
extend beyond its planet to its
immediate astronomical environment might
even be large-scale Astro engineering we
could look for that supposing we found
something like that it wouldn't be a
message it wouldn't be contact with
aliens but it would mean we could say
definitely that there is or was somebody
out there that they're these are the
fruits of their intelligent activity now
that would be in my view the most
profound scientific discovery in the
history of mankind and its impact would
be a little bit like when Copernicus
announced that the earth is going around
the Sun there was no change in the price
of beer no rioting in the streets
nothing of that sort and yet over the
centuries it is enormous ly colored the
way we see ourselves and our place in
the universe same thing with Darwin's
theory of evolution okay no rioting no
dramatic changes in society but over the
decades very definitely he had has
changed the way we think
think about ourselves and in the same
way we knew we were not alone in the
universe it would have a very very deep
impact on our worldview on a
understanding of our place in the
universe but I think it could be
announced in the same way
well not quite in the same ways
Copernicus he waited till he died before
he published it because he was afraid of
being killed by the church but we don't
have that fear I don't think but I think
it could be announced in the same way as
a major astronomical discovery with a
published paper and a press conference
and all the rest of it now that's one
extreme and that's the most likely thing
that we're going to find but the other
extreme is the holy grail of SETI which
is the message you know a message from
ET for mankind Earthlings have I got
news for you that's all the thing and
then all bets are off because the effect
of such a message could be enormous ly
disruptive if it's a message with
content we have to think what is that
content we can imagine all sorts of
things ranging from stop burning fossil
fuels you silly people you're heating
your planet - there's a comet coming
your way you're going to be wiped out in
a hundred years or it could be a more
healthful thing along the lines of here
is a way of gaining control over nuclear
fusion to give yourself a cheap energy
source now these things will all have
enormous impacts on society even just
some helpful tips about technology would
change the economic and technological
balance of the planet and could be very
very disruptive so we would need to
think very carefully about how that sort
of information was handled we'd also
need to think very carefully about
whether we should reply and if so what
should we say and who speaks for Earth
and that gets us into all sorts of
difficult territory but the one thing I
think we're all agreed with this task
group is that we should not disclose the
coordinates in the sky of any
transmitting sauce suppose we knew that
up there is some alien civilization and
it's sending radio signals their way we
should not tell the public where that is
we can say that we've got which we
picked up a signal we shall tell them
we're for the simple reason and that
anybody could commandeer a radio
telescope set themselves up
some self-appointed spokesperson of
mankind and start being me all sorts of
crazy messages back to the aliens I
think if we're going to send messages to
the stars then it needs a great deal of
thought that it's something that should
involve the entire not only scientific
community but the entire world community
we need to think very carefully indeed
so that should be prevented but SETI is
not a secret enterprise and this task
group is itself a completely public it's
completely open our conclusions are
available on the Internet
it's it's not anything we want to keep
from the public but the but the effects
are very sobering we do really do have
to think about what the effect on
society would be and and the effect on
religion for example could be very very
profound and we know what an explosive
issue religion is on planet earth so
those are the sorts of things we
deliberate on